[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniel hablando con nuestro estudio
Daniela bienvenida y vamos a hablar del
gobierno argentino que busca acabar con
una práctica común entre los turistas
Hola Raúl pues hoy en día un turista lo
que hace normalmente y muchos lo hemos
hecho es llegar cargado de dólares para
cambiarlos Por lo general en el mercado
Paralelo que lo paga mucho mejor que el
oficial desde el viernes entró en
vigencia una norma con la que se van a
liquidar los pagos con tarjetas traídas
del exterior a un precio más alto de la
actual nuestro corresponsable Buenos
Aires Natalia nos Explica en qué
consiste concretamente este incentivo
los turistas que llegan al país saben
que no les conviene gastar con tarjeta
de crédito Por lo menos hasta ahora
porque un gasto en tarjeta les estaría
dando por cada dólar que gasten unos 150
pesos en cambio Si traen ese dinero en
efectivo y lo cambian en el mercado
paralelo reciben entre 290 y 300 Por eso
llegan con grandes cantidades de
efectivo por eso Esas imágenes de
turistas pagando cenas con muchísimos
billetes de pesos pero la decisión del
gobierno Busca en todo caso desalentar
esa alternativa y darle un beneficio del
turismo para que utilice plásticos
tarjeta de crédito tarjetas de débito
tarjetas preparadas porque ahora lo que
prevén es darles el mismo cambio que les
da más o menos el mismo cambio que les
da el Paralelo es una ventaja es mucho
más fácil andar pagando con tarjetas de
crédito no ir con efectivo encima además
es una cuestión de seguridad no ir
cargando con efectivo es más seguro y es
menos engorroso hay que ver si
finalmente los turistas deciden
adoptarlo hubo otros intentos que no
funcionaron pero eran muchísimo más en
por ejemplo abrir una cuenta en
Argentina y depositar esos dólares aquí
y luego empezar a operar es algo que un
turista que viene por pocos días
Posiblemente no quiere hacer si este
mecanismo de las tarjetas funciona bien
y es adoptado por el turismo va a
permitir un mayor ingreso de Divisas al
circuito oficial en Argentina eso es
algo importante es algo que necesita el
país dólares en el circuito oficial se
estima que hoy entran tal vez unos 30
millones de dólares por mes de turismo
receptivo y se espera que con esta
medida si funciona bien llegue a los 200
millones O tal vez un poco más 200
millones de dólares por mes que entran
en el circuito oficial en Argentina Es
que Daniela no hay que olvidar que el
peso argentino es el más desvalorizado
en nuestra región el más desvalorizado
junto con el peso colombiano que han
sufrido con más fuerza no solamente
factores internos sino el gran auge que
está teniendo el dólar esta situación
que no solamente obedece a lo que está
sucediendo en cada país pues también
sucede por las decisiones que se están
tomando en Estados Unidos nos
consultamos con el analista Daniel
Escobar Cómo llegamos hasta aquí
básicamente es un tema de un escenario
que no se había descontado y que nos
está llevando a etapas que no vayamos
hace unos 40 años en varias economías
como en el caso de Estados Unidos la
inflación ha sido tan alta que la
reserva Federal El Banco Central de
ellos pues ha sido muy agresivo en sus
incrementos de tasas de interés no se
tenía contemplado Esto hace 12 meses y
cada mes ya ha venido revisando al alto
expectativa de tasa de interés eso por
un lado genera expectativa de que el
dólar se fortalezca mucho porque el
estado de interés pueden ya llegar a ser
un poco más atractiva de lo que era en
el pasado y segundo mucha salsa estado
de interés está asociado también a un
riesgo de una recesión y en recesión nos
asusta mucho lo que pueda pasar en el
resto del mundo y la gente se refugiando
en el dólar Estos son todos canales que
genera como un se refuerzan entre sí y
ha generado un fortalecimiento
generalizado del dólar en todo en todo
el mundo aunque no lo puede predecir el
futuro si puede ir al pasado para ver
cuándo se acelera esa subi el valor del
dólar y se ha acelerado cuando la
reserva Federal modifica su visión de
cuánto va a subir las tasas de interés
Sí y cada vez que las eleva más pues el
mercado se vuelve sensible y el dólar se
fortaleza y como ya sabemos también hay
pocos países que se salvan de esta
devaluación sí Raúl pues vamos a ver en
el siguiente rap gráfico algunas
referencias de cómo se han vendido
comportando algunas monedas frente al
dólar estadounidense por ejemplo el
dólar canadiense ha perdido un 7,8% el
euro un 13,6%, el peso colombiano casi
un 20% y el peso argentino
34,8%. pero también hay que decir que
hay Tres monedas que se salvan que son
el rublo ruso el real brasileño y el
peso mexicano el primero por los
controles cambiarios que se han aplicado
desde que inició la Guerra pero veamos
qué opina también nuestro invitado
frente a las otras monedas
en América Latina tú tienes a México muy
buena estructura del lado fiscal o por
lo menos no tan
débil eso le da algo de respaldo Brasil
muy buena estructural del sector externo
venden más de lo que compran
internacionalmente por lo menos tienen
una situación más balanceada pero chile
y Colombia tiene una debilidad digamos
un poco más latente y sus monedas han
sido muy fuertemente afectadas
últimamente bueno y de esta manera
entonces finalizamos este bloque
económico por el día de hoy Dani
Muchísimas gracias como siempre nos
vemos este lunes con más información
económica